[Music]
this week on q a historian ron chernow
mr chernow talks about the hit broadway
musical hamilton
and the consulting work he did on it
the show's creator lin manuel miranda
based the musical on mr chernow's
biography of alexander hamilton
[Music]
ron chernow when did hamilton alexander
hamilton
first
get on your radar screen
well i started um writing it back in
1998 brian it seems rather comical
because the reason that i chose to
do alexander hamilton aside from the
fact that it was the most extraordinary
personal story among the founding
fathers was that he seemed to be fading
into obscurity people were
coming to regard him as a sort of
second-tier
founding father most americans knew he
was on the 10 bill maybe that he had
died in a duel with aaron burr but that
was about it it seems comical that i was
felt as if i was lifting him out of
obscurity now his name is on the marquis
broadway show
but when where were you at the time what
did what were you doing i just finished
writing my biography of john d
rockefeller titan and what happened i'd
done a series of books about moguls of
the gilded age and i found that when i
would go out to give lectures people in
the audience would start shouting out do
vanderbilt next do carnegie next and i
really felt that i was becoming terribly
stereotyped as this biographer of gilded
age tycoons and i decided that i wanted
to switch periods and so alexander
hamilton was the perfect exit strategy
because i knew there would be a lot of
financial and economic history but it
also exposed me not only to a new era
but foreign affairs constitutional law
you know military history on and on and
on uh plus the most amazing um story
that i've ever written
you probably don't like this question i
asked it before not of you but of others
is there someone today that would come
closest to the way alexander hamilton
thought about government
thought about government um that's a
very difficult question uh brian i will
say this that um alexander hamilton was
the most
verbal
politician in our history if he felt
strongly
about an issue he would sit down and he
would write a series of 25
essays over the course of a few weeks
about it and i think that hamilton would
fit very uncomfortably
into an era of tweets and sound bites
he was very
rational
deeply intellectual and principled and i
can't think of anyone stylistically
certainly
who reminds me of alexander hamilton
today good that we had him on the scene
2004 your book comes out it's number one
on the paperback seller list and on the
combined new york times list it's in the
top 15
all these years later well
actually us as we talk uh six months on
the paperback bestseller list and five
straight weeks
uh at number one for an 800-page book
that was published
in 2004. i think it's safe to say that
that is unprecedented it's really quite
extraordinary what's it done to your
life
well um it's had a profound effect this
has been very much a through the looking
glass experience for me the greatest
thrill of course has been having
lin-manuel miranda take this biography
and translate it into a very vivid
three-dimensional life on the stage but
it's also been deeply touching to me the
way that i've been completely embraced
and incorporated into the world of the
show not only the creative team but the
cast members and because i'd never been
involved
with the show before maybe never will be
again i decided that i wanted to have
every experience that could possibly go
with the broadway show i was at every
workshop and theater festival and
rehearsal
i sat in on the recording of the cast
album uh i sat in one performance with
the orchestra in this kind of black
grotto under the the stage and i'd been
a lifelong
theater goer never imagined that i would
be on the other side of the footlight so
it's just been absolutely enchanting
experience as you watched it up close
be made what was the most difficult part
of it most difficult part well you know
in in my book
i have hundreds of characters
um one thing that i immediately realized
was that
history
is long messy and complicated broadway
shows have to be very short coherent and
tightly constructed and there is a
conflict between that in a broadway
musical you have to have eight or ten
principal characters everything has to
happen to them by them through them you
have to establish them early keep on
developing them and so um there are
certain places uh in the show where
things happen accurately but actually
we're done by or two other people for
instance there's a a scene in the show
um where uh jefferson burn madison
confront hamilton with the reynolds
scandal he actually was confronted by
three jeffersonians but not those three
individuals so lynn
what i loved working with him is in
those cases where he felt um obliged to
use dramatic license he would always try
to incorporate as many authentic
elements into the scene as he could even
if he had changed something
if you get on the website today
first of all you can't buy tickets or
sold out for how far are they sold out
sold out as we talk through january 2017
so all of this year
and and then january of next year but if
you get on and get on these resale
uh websites a thousand dollars might get
you a ticket yeah i mean um people have
been scalping tickets for fifteen
hundred two thousand twenty five hundred
dollars
uh a ticket uh certainly routinely
scalping for a thousand or fifteen
hundred dollars
a ticket what do you think about that
what do you think of that well you know
it's been frustrating for us because um
uh we didn't create this show
exclusively for hedge fund managers and
private equity uh people and we've been
doing uh what is within our power to try
to offset that for instance there's a
lottery every night
where the entire first row um
people get tickets for ten dollars a
piece if they win the lottery we also
have starting in april every wednesday
there's going to be a matinee
for new york city school children
actually 11th graders
who are in
so-called title 1 schools free lunch
school so they'll be mostly black and
latino audience 1300 kids wednesday
matinees will be sitting there for ten
dollars apiece and not only will they
see this extraordinary show where it's
impossible to get tickets
they're going to have a q a
with the cast afterwards
their teachers have been supplied with
curricular materials so that the
teachers can use the show actually as a
vehicle you know for teaching more about
american history so
we're trying to broaden out the audience
we're well aware of this problem it's a
nice problem to have but it is a problem
you got the washington prize for which
book i got the washington prize actually
for alexander hamilton and so did lin
years later right and and they asked me
to get up there and pay tribute
uh to him at the awards center hold on
i want to show you a piece of tape right
now from that award ceremony here's ron
chernow
now i know that you're all expecting me
to stand up here and start snapping my
fingers and breaking into rhyme couplets
but i'm afraid i'm going to disappoint
you although i have to say one side of
me is dying to do
exactly that and i'm going to do it
how does a bastard orphan son of a [ __ ]
and the scotsman dropped in the middle
of her forgot no i'm not going there lin
i'm not going there i'm not going
[Applause]
in caribbean by providence impoverished
and squalor grew up to be a hero and a
scholar someone saved me
no i've told kind of like adam i've had
this fantasy about going on the stage
and i've told lynn that i'd like to go
on and just do the opening number they
could then pull me off with the hook
afterwards but
for some mysterious reason lynn has
decided not to draw on my unique
theatrical talents
how hard was that to do i've never seen
lynn laugh as hard he and his family
were sitting at a table right in front
of the podium and he just doubled over
with laughter and when he got up on the
stage to receive the word he said i
can't believe it we have ron chernow
wrapping on c-span so it's been recorded
i actually did it but that has been a
fantasy of mine to go on for the opening
number as you know it's a two-hour and a
55-minute show yes and the music you can
buy all the music
uh how much of this can you do by by
memory
oh i can i can do most of the the first
song i know lots of different uh
portions
of of the show i mean brian i've seen
i've seen the show about 50 times and of
course i was very intimately
involved over a six or seven year period
with the creation of the show in fact
when i first started working with lynn
as he wrote each song he would send it
to me via email i would just hear lin at
the keyboard
singing and he would send them with
these kind of psychedelic screens
as i heard him singing and i was
absolutely
astonished in fact he came over and he
sang the opening
number
came up to my apartment started snapping
his fingers he was sitting on my living
room couch and he started singing how
does a bastard or the son of or and when
he was finished
doing it he said what do you think this
was my first exposure to it and i said i
think that's the most extraordinary
thing you've taken the first
40 minutes
of my first 40 pages of my book
and condensed them accurately into a
four and a half minute song what i
didn't say to lynn but i was thinking it
thinking boy this guy writes very tight
or i right very long it was a little
embarrassing that he had you know
distilled
the 40 pages down to a four four and a
half minutes song and had done it so
accurately we have a photo of uh
lin-manuel miranda with your book in
hand and he's in the water
uh is that when he first got this book
yes what happened when i met lynn in
november uh 2008 he was still starring
in his first show in the heights um he
invited me to a
sunday matinee and i went backstage and
i'd heard from mutual friend that he had
read the book
on vacation and made enormous impression
and he said to me ryan i was reading
your book
on vacation mexico and as i was reading
it hip-hop songs started rising off the
page and i said really and then he
started telling me he said you know
hamilton's life is a
classic hip-hop narrative and i was
thinking what on earth is this guy
talking about i think that lynn quickly
uh picked up the fact that he had a
world-class ignoramus about hip-hop on
his hands and he said to me on the spot
because my first question to him was
um can hip-hop
be the vehicle for telling this kind of
you know very
large and complex story and he said ron
i'm going to educate you
about hip-hop and he did on the spot he
started pointing out that hip-hop you
can pack
more information into the lyrics than
any other form because it's very very
dense and rapid he started talking about
the fact that hip-hop not only has
rhymed endings it has internal rhyme it
has wordplay started educating me in all
these different devices that are very
very important to the success of the of
the show so i'm not a complete ignoramus
um about hip-hop anymore just mostly
yeah is there anything in the show that
that uh you've directly had an impact on
oh absolutely um i in terms of um
the relationship between hamilton and
washington for instance
uh i was having lynch lunch with lynn
one day and he said to me he was trying
to figure out what's the dramatic
essence of that relationship which is
very central to the show and he said to
me would um
with washington when he met hamilton
during the revolutionary war would
washington have seen hamilton as a
younger version
of himself and i said absolutely
because washington when he meets
hamilton hamilton is 22. well when
washington was 23 he was
the head of all the armed forces in
virginia
led his men into a terrible massacre at
a place called fort necessity and in
fact there's this beautiful
uh song in the show where washington
sings let me tell you what i wish i'd
known when i was young and dreamed of
glory well that was very thrilling to me
when we had that discussion and then the
next time
i saw a new version of the show to see
that scene
and that song and realize that it came
directly out of it but even even brian
you know uh very late
um in the game for instance even when it
was at the
public theater where it originated
off-broadway
um i said to lynn munda i said you know
there's one big policy point that is
missing from the show which is that when
hamilton became treasury secretary the
country was bankrupt and by the time he
left five years later
we were as creditworthy as any other
country in the world an amazing feat and
so what he has in the closing scene of
the show
madison comes out and says he took us
from bankruptcy
to prosperity and you know for that will
ever forever be in uh his debt and uh he
doesn't get enough credit for all the
credit
that he gave us well that was a direct
response to what i had said and that was
actually um
pretty late in the
off-broadway run of the show so it was
great i mean the beautiful thing about
working with lynn is that
he's always prepared to listen
he was
very good at
filtering out
whatever ridiculous or asinine things
that i would say he had very good
instincts if i said something that
really hit home to him he was always
fully uh open to it and and he was
diplomatic because if i said something
that he thought was uh completely
absurd he wouldn't disagree
he would simply
stare at me wordless
that i would realize that i had goofed
you were born where i was born in
brooklyn
and
uh mr miranda was born where
uh lynn was born um in in new york i
assume on the upper west side
and alexander hamilton was born where
and where was he raised uh hamilton was
born on the island of nevis in the
caribbean he spent his
uh adolescence on saint croix one of the
virgin islands and around the age of 17
a killer hurricane hit the island he
wrote this very brilliant
letter that was published in the island
newspaper describing in almost
shakespearean terms this hurricane he
was an illegitimate you know orphaned
impoverished clerk at that point the
local merchant suddenly recognized that
they had this young genius in their
midst and they took up a collection
to send him to the north american
colonies to be educated he came armed
with a few letters of introduction but
he didn't know
a soul and so hamilton is not only the
original
immigrant but a completely
uh self-made and really self-invented
figure you know all the other founding
fathers they were either virginia
planters or boston lawyers they were all
born in the original 13 colonies
hamilton was the
outsider and started out life with as
many disadvantages as most of those
figures had
advantages it's an amazing story we can
only use obviously a little bit of the
music but here's about 20 seconds and
it's alexander hamilton uh the tune is
stay alive and uh the reason to run this
is it shows about his relationship with
uh general eisenhower at the time and at
the time he was an aide to general
eisenhower's how old would he have been
talking about general washington yeah
general eisenhower
[Laughter]
well hamilton is um is 22
when he meets washington washington
would have been 45
at that point let's just listen to a
little bit of something in flavor
i have never seen the general so
despondent i have taken over writing all
his correspondence congress rides george
attacked the british forces i shoot back
we have resorted to eating our horses
local merchants deny us equipment
assistance they only take british money
so sing a song
that's it for the moment yeah but uh
what are you very accurate in fact
because all of these you know farmers uh
this was the valley forge winter there
um the continental army was actually
sitting there
amidst plenty the problem was not the
availability food the problem was that
the farmers were selling the food
to the british forces uh
in philadelphia and i remember lynn had
actually
sent me very beautiful sad
mournful
music
for valley forge and you would hear the
words of thomas payne
over the the music and those were the
only words that survived from that
original
draft of that scene but lin is
extraordinary in terms of you know
plucking out
exactly what he needs for scene he's
self-critical
and he's a very disciplined writer it's
always very hard for
a writer to strike out a beautiful line
that he's written lynn has the ability
to do it i'm not sure i do but he does
he is about what age right now uh linus
36
and when the constitutional convention
was held and alexander hamilton was
there and james madison they were what
30 36 for
uh let's see because um
uh hamilton was born by my count uh
1755 said he would have been 32
and then 34 when he became treasury
secretary so all of this is
except for your case
have been done by really young people
yeah and this actually very interesting
point brian because i think that so much
of the attention about the show
has
has concentrated on the fact that it's
um this black and latino
narration and biracial cast of course
that's a great novelty for show about
the founding fathers one that startled
me at the beginning but i think that the
thing that has not been sufficiently
emphasized
is how young the actors are you know i
grew up with the musical i'm sure you
did 1776
and it was a bunch of late middle-aged
you know white factors and wigs and
buckle shoes here there are very few
people in the cast who are over
40 and so i think in the same way that
this
you know black and latino
cast
enables the um audience to um
enter into this experience it provides a
kind of bridge for the audience between
the sensibility of today and the
sensibility of of them but i think that
the fact that um the show reminds us
that the american revolution like
revolutions throughout history
are made by young people and i think
that that's very exciting and it really
hasn't been talked about as you know at
that ceremony when lynn miranda got the
washington award the gilderlairman folks
said they were they were going to fund
20 000 young people seeing it is that
actually we got a grant from the
rockefeller foundation uh so um we'll
have uh one wednesday matinee a month uh
we'll have uh 11th graders um why 11th
graders uh because they're studying
american history they're studying this
uh period in their classrooms that's i
think really howard how far has that
gone nationwide
well um you know we
we have now in the works three maybe
another four uh productions and so um
there'll be a chicago production opening
in um uh september october it's to be in
la next year for five months san
francisco for five months there'll be
one maybe two national touring companies
and so i'm hoping that
and then it's going to be in london in
fall of 2017. so i'm hoping that as the
show goes to other cities that if not
the rockefeller foundation that another
local philanthropy
will do exactly what we're doing in new
york again for reasons stated earlier
this is our single most important
audience out there and thank god
from the time the cast album came out
last october the last figure i saw it
had already sold 252 000 copies it's the
complete show it's almost every word of
the uh of the show
it's two cds it has the complete
libretto uh inside and so i think that
the cast album
um as much as the show
has enabled
the hamilton musical to really
enter into
american popular culture and political
culture in a way that i've never seen
with a broadway show i'm getting every
day i get an email from some friends
saying you know my six-year-old is
driving me crazy she sits in a room all
day listening to the cast album again
and again and i write back and say you
know there are worse problems for a
parent than having a child who only
wants to talk about the founding fathers
you know whoever thought that would be a
problem this is what the libretto looks
like and inside the uh the cds that you
get
and if you haven't been to the show you
have to read this as you go to know
who's talking exactly um and you know
the wonderful thing is ryan we really
have two audiences for this show we have
the audience inside the theater and
that's
1 321 people
every night so maybe what about 10 000
people a week but i feel as if we
actually have a much much larger
audience
across the country of people who are
reading the uh who are listening to the
cast album who are reading the libretto
and um newsweek online really recently
did an issue that uh teachers across the
country
um are already using the show and using
the cast album as an educational tool
then there'll be a certain moment i
don't know how far down the road this
will be where the producers will allow
schools to start to license the show
that is to actually perform the show and
i think we all
feel and all hope that this is going to
be the single most widely
uh produced musicals
in american schools for many many years
i'm sure it will be here's len miranda
outside of the richard rogers theater
back in august of 2015 when he would
come out and entertain the folks that
are waiting there in line let's watch it
uh it is very rare that we uh get to
lottery tickets for an opening night of
a show
[Applause]
for making that possible i i i wish you
all luck i wish we could get you all in
there but i hope you all come see the
show thanks to you i think we're going
to run a nice long time
in the early 1850s few pedestrians
strolling past the house on h street in
washington near the white house realized
that the ancient widow seated by the
window knitting and arranging flowers
was the last surviving link to the glory
days of the early republic
50 years earlier on a rocky secluded
ledge overlooking the hudson river in
weehawken new jersey aaron burr the vice
president of the united states had fired
a mortal shot at her husband alexander
hamilton in a misbegotten effort to
remove the man burr regarded as the main
impediment to the advancement of his
career
that was actually um opening night on
broadway
lynn came out about two hours before the
show started and he read the opening
paragraphs of of my book and i was very
startled when i saw the clip because
there are a couple of moments where he's
almost on the edge of tears as he's
reading it and as powerful as i knew his
emotional response had been to the book
when i saw that i learned something new
about just how deeply he'd felt it and
we were both we both fell in love with
eliza hamilton who had been a completely
unknown figure to the american public
before that and i think we really have
changed that
here is len miranda at the same ceremony
where you did the wrap
uh so people can see a little bit more
she's speaking of what he's like
and ron's version of hamilton is what
made me fall in love
the first two chapters of ron's book out
dickens dickens in terms of the hardship
hamilton faces and the incredible odds
he overcame to come to this country and
helped shape it
um
and it's been an incredible journey
working with ron
and and learning about this history and
and i think the secret sauce of the show
is i'm learning the stuff just a chapter
ahead of you
um i'm falling in love with these
characters and
i'm falling in love with the fact that
they're not the people i grew up
learning about in ap us history
they're flawed and they're messy
burr came alive to me when i realized he
was dating theodosia provost when she
was still married to that guy who was a
general down in bermuda
and i said oh this is a guy who waits
for what he wants and that unlocked a
burr for me
explain more about aaron burr and what
he's talking about
yeah no the way that lin presents the um
hamilton burr
conflict um
not just at the very end of hamilton's
life but throughout was
that they were uh rivals and then
presents them as having very very
contrasting personalities which i think
is true
that hamilton is a very aggressive and
self-confident person who's not afraid
to you know grab what he wants
burr plays everything close to the vest
bear was a much more cautious and kind
of crafty individual and he would hang
back
and
during the war
burr fell in love with the wife of a
british officer and there's a scene in
the show
where hamilton says to him if you love
this woman why don't you go get her
and it's meant really to point out
the
difference in personality between the
two men as time goes on of course the
difference in politics and ideology will
become you know even that much more
important so that's what lynn is
referring to
as long as we're on this a fair thing
between burr and theodosia
you mentioned this earlier and we've got
some a little excerpt from the the
program about the reynolds pamphlet
right which which you you write about in
your book obviously but you can also
find it on the internet a whole pamphlet
this pamphlet before we run this was
written when
1797 and what was the reason well what
happened was well hamilton was treasury
secretary uh one day a very beautiful 23
year old woman named mariah reynolds
came to his door
she spilled out this woeful tale that
she'd been abandoned by her husband
james reynolds that she was in need of
money
and hamilton believe it or not hamilton
was then the most powerful and
controversial man in the american
government that night hamilton slipped
out of the house
went to her rooming house
said that he found
mariah reynolds at the top of a
staircase she said
she then ushered him into a bedroom and
then he wrote
his famous line and she then made it
clear that other than pecuniary
consolation
would be acceptable and that was the
start of an affair that went on for a
year but after about a month or so
mr reynolds suddenly appeared and
instead of stopping the affair decided
that it would be much more fun to charge
hamilton
for the pleasure of his wife's company
in bed and incredibly enough i mean it
was so reckless
of hamilton to have entered into she had
been a prostitute mariah reynolds uh it
was so reckless and self-destructive of
him to
to enter into the affair to begin with
but then suddenly he's paying hush money
to the husband when all of the
jeffersonian press is circling around
him trying to get some
dirt on him and here hamilton is giving
them the the biggest story that they
would ever
get isn't there a bit of a difference in
the in the broadway show from the actual
way it happened yes it's a very good
point and you were asking before if
there were things where my comments
changed something uh what happened in
actuality was that uh a
scandal-mongering journalist named james
t calendar who was a kind of
jeffersonian hitman of the era
published these charges uh claiming that
hamilton had paid money to mr james
reynolds because they were
secretly engaging in speculation and
treasury securities together
hamilton then publishes this pamphlet
saying oh no no i was paying money to
james reynolds but it was for the favor
of his wife's company and actually i
said to um to lynn i thought that it was
a little confusing
to the audience because in the show it
seemed as if hamilton is aware was
preemptively publishing this pamphlet
after jefferson madison very told
him that they know about these
payments
because lynn did not have the pamphlet
that provoked hamilton's pamphlet so
lynn
added a line at the end of that scene
with a burr jefferson madison where
um
burr says alexander rumors only grow
and that line came out of
you know my saying to lynn i'm afraid
the audience is going to wonder why he
preemptively published
this
pamphlet here's 20 seconds and thomas
jefferson james madison
angelica
the
is in this along with aaron burr and uh
hamilton let's just listen a little bit
so you can get the flavor of it
[Music]
alexander hamilton
and he wrote it down right there
[Music]
with all
of the success you had with alexander
hamilton back in 2004
are you finding people that are learning
uh a lot more about alexander hamilton
and these founders now that this thing
has become right every single time i'm
at the theater and i'm there fairly
often at least one person comes up to me
and says you know ron i love the show
and as i was watching the show i was
embarrassed to realize how little i knew
about the history of my own country and
i'm determined to change that
very nice that a lot of them are then
going out and reading the book or
reading other books about the founding
europe so i said to lynn at that awards
ceremony that you showed before i said
to him afterwards i said you know lynn i
don't know
what your next show was going to be i
said
you have had
an
impact in terms of stimulating an
interest in american history of sort
that i've never
seen i said to him i just hope that you
periodically in your career keep
circling back to american history
because i think brian you know probably
every biographer is doing you've
interviewed over the years all of them
would say the same thing that we really
didn't feel that we were reaching the
young people i find that when i go out
and do a lecture or a book signing you
know typically the audience is about 35
40 years old enough sometimes 60 70 you
know 80
whereas lynn seems to have this magical
connection with people of
all ages um believe it or not a friend
even told me that she took her
three-year-old to see the show and the
little girl was sort of bouncing and
swaying uh in her seat i've also seen
the show with people in their late 80s
who were as starry-eyed you know
as that child and so that this is uh
lynn is worth his his weight in in gold
in terms of um
stimulating young people to read about
american history how important uh to the
success of this show was his appearance
back in 2009
at the white house in front of the first
lady and the president well it was i
have to say from a personal standpoint
it was very very helpful because you
have to understand that for the you know
six or seven years we were working on
this before people actually saw the show
um i would say you know i'm involved in
this uh show it's it's going to be a
musical hip-hop musical about the
founding fathers
and they would look at me
like i was crazy it was a little bit
like uh the the show where the movie the
producers where they're trying to come
up with the single worst idea of all
time for music and they come up with
springtime for hitler i mean it was a
little bit like i was saying i'm in this
wonderful
involved with this wonderful musical
it's called spring time for hitler i
mean that was how people were reacting
to the idea of a musical the hip-hop
musical about the founder of oz in fact
right before the show opened a downtown
at the public theater i was walking
near the theater one day and i passed
these two young women on the street
and i heard one say to the other
and it's a musical about alexander
hamilton and then they both started
laughing
and then the woman said and it's in
hip-hop and then they just were standing
there on the sidewalk roaring with the
laughter well the wonderful thing about
that white house clip is that when
people would start laughing at me i
would say well watch that clip
uh from the white house that was 2009 i
said watch the clip let me know what you
think and uh everyone
uh who saw the click clip then would
call me up and say oh my god that was
quite extraordinary let's watch 40
seconds of it now yeah
um i'm thrilled the white house called
me uh tonight uh because uh i'm actually
working on a hip-hop album uh it's a
concept album about the life of someone
i think embodies hip-hop treasury
secretary alexander hamilton
you laugh but it's true he was uh he was
born a penniless orphan
in saint croix of illegitimate birth
became george washington's right-hand
man
became treasury secretary caught beef
with every other founding father
uh and all on the strength of his
writing i think he embodies uh the words
ability to make a difference
what um
what has happened to lynn miranda in all
this
what's success meant to him and and how
long can he keep starring in this every
night well i think that he's uh he's
already said that he's going to stay in
the show through july that is he
announced from the beginning that he was
going to stay in the show for
a year for this simple reason i think he
would like to be on to his next show and
they're doing eight performances a week
it's very difficult uh for him to uh
kind of clear his mind for the next show
in fact he i recently heard him say in
an interview that when he took my book
down on vacation to mexico it was
actually the first break that he had had
from in the heights where he could sort
of open his mind
to another uh story but i think the show
has made him
a superstar people are running after him
with every conceivable uh offer but i
think that
um
if there's one thing that i've learned
about lynn he's the original
multi-tasker because the years that he
was sending me the hamilton songs and
there would be sporadic
uh rehearsals you know he's maintained
um psychological continuity with the
show so i um i i think that lynn
probably has another six eight ten
wonderful musicals um in him and i hope
that some of them uh revolve around
american history i know it's private but
i'll ask a question anyway
from a financial standpoint for yourself
do they have to buy your services they
have to buy the rights
well lynn optioned lynn optioned the
book
but the interesting thing is ryan that
the book came out in 2004
and the book was
optioned three times
in hollywood for feature film and as
often happens when a book is optioned
disappears into a kind of black hole
uh and uh hollywood i guess couldn't
figure out what to do with the story and
i kept saying to my agent here and the
agent and my age in l.a i said i don't
get it here's the story this
illegitimate orphan kid comes out of
nowhere sets the world on fire you want
sex there's a sex scandal you want
violence there's a duel on and it has
all of the ingredients one could
possibly want and hollywood couldn't
figure out what to do with it lin-manuel
miranda at the end of the second chapter
knew exactly what he wanted
to do with it
in your book in the back and the
acknowledgments
you say that there was a study underway
to try to find out whether alexander
hamilton was uh a black right and you
said the information is going to come
later what happened right well you know
what happened was was this i discovered
from geneticists that
if i had
direct
male hamilton descendants that is
descendants who were guys who had the
hamilton
name
i had them swabbing out their mouths and
then sending the the swabs off to a lab
for genetic testing and the results were
inclusive i was thinking to myself
frankly
wouldn't it be great for race relations
in this country if we suddenly had a you
know a biracial
uh founding father but doing it was very
instructive for me because it made me
realize that
race which we in america tend to think
of as something very
precise and distinct
becomes very nebulous you know on the
genetic level what we it turns out we
have
the so-called races have much more in
common
with each other than differences so to
kind of look at the genetic material
from someone and try to determine what
race they were
was very difficult but you know when
hamilton came to
north america he was illegitimate and he
always said you know my birth has been
the subject of the most humiliating you
know criticisms uh he was always stung
by references to his illegitimacy but
there was also in in in the press you
know john adams called them the creole
bastard there were
a lot of different references to his
racial makeup for the simple reason that
very often uh when you know young people
came from the caribbean in those years
the caribbean islands were
sugar and
cotton slave plantations
it was not unusual for them to be the
product of a union between a you know a
white uh
master and a female uh slave but
hamilton we have a lot of paintings of
him uh his coloring was very kind of
ruddy and scottish so not apparent from
just looking at the pictures of him that
he would have been
biracial and so um i think that
as
i
tell in the book
his father may not have been
james hamilton
may have been a man named thomas stevens
because hamilton as many people remarked
in later years hamilton's best friend
from boyhood
was someone named ned stevens who became
a very eminent doctor and um everyone
who knew hamilton who then suddenly
had the chance to meet ned stevens was
bowled over by
the resemblance and said that they
looked like
uh brothers which makes me think that
they probably were i think that lynn in
the show decided that you know that was
probably one complication
uh too many and decided not to deal with
that which would have been difficult to
deal with because he starts the show
um 1776 in that opening song he tells us
everything that we need to know up until
that point in uh hamilton's life and
that would have been quite a bomb show
to drop into that first song here is
some more video from that event that uh
you were all
uh in attendance in 2015 that get the
washington award by the way was that
fifty thousand dollars i think so
you got it
i i i think so yeah i think that's
accurate
[Laughter]
i'm past patiently waiting i'm
passionately smashing every expectation
every action's enacted creation i'm
laughing in the face of casualties of
sorrow it's the first time i'm thinking
past tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's actually the trailer uh from the
show that they uh used to publicize it
uh you were saying off camera that those
are your that's your family now i'm
running this is a very hip cool crowd
now you know i just kind of changed my
life certainly has changed my image uh
around town and um it has just been so
moving for me that they have invited me
into their
world
um
any chance we're going to see you on
stage at some point
no although i am hoping that uh june
12th tony night i am hoping that i will
be up on the stage if we
do win for best musical which i think we
have a reasonable chance
of doing but i don't think i'll be up on
the stage with the richard rodgers
theater although i keep mentioning it as
a as a possibility i can't figure out
why they don't want to have me in the
show alexander hamilton
just took him off the main things that
he did uh anybody died at 49 i think
you're saying yeah another people would
say 47 but okay i mean you know the the
revolutionary there were three main acts
the first act uh winning the
revolutionary war hamilton was
washington's aid to camp chief of staff
and a battlefield hero
at yorktown the second act
constitutional convention it was
hamilton who personally issued the plea
for a constitutional convention to meet
in philadelphia in may 1787.
he was the sole new york delegate uh to
sign it he then um originated and wrote
51 of the 85 um essays of the federalist
papers considered the classic gloss on
the constitution became a third act
creation of the federal government
becomes the first treasury secretary at
age 34.
um he
creates the treasury department which
means he creates the first tax system
first accounting system first fiscal
system first monetary system first
central bank first coast guard first
custom service on and on and on brothers
hamilton was the architect of the
federal government
did you like alexander hamilton after
you lived with him for so long well you
know on the one hand hamilton was very
um he was very charming he was very
witty he was very charismatic it was
very easy to like that side of him but
he was also brash and headstrong and
dangerously
sure of himself and often
self-destructive and bad judgment and so
i had tremendous
admiration for what hamilton had
accomplished i often say to people the
wonderful thing about this story is that
hamilton's accomplishments
were so monumental that you could admire
him
but his flaws were so serious that we
can all identify with him you know so
that he's both
at once um very human and uh superhuman
depending upon the the moments uh it's
uh it's a fascinating story that someone
who was uh as brilliant as uh hamilton
was as flawed and fallible as he is and
it was interesting because when we were
creating the show there's always this
notion that in a broadway musical
the central character should be
sympathetic you know you should be
rooting for that central character and
hamilton with the reynolds pamphlet and
other things that happen
in the second act hamilton is constantly
testing the sympathy
of the audience and it's been very
interesting that people walk out of the
theater
not only with tremendous admiration
but affection for him and i realize the
reason is because
he became real to them you know this is
the big mistake i think that we make in
our schools in terms of teaching history
we think that in order to instill love
of historical figures to instill love of
american history that we should present
a series of uh saints
and the students are very bored and the
figures seem completely unreal if you
can kind of capture them accurately they
will love these characters where did you
go to high school
i went um to farsel's high school in
queens and then i did uh two degrees in
english literature one at yale and one
at uh
at cambridge so i never studied history
in school but when you look back at
school you must have had some history
classes
some history and um do you remember them
at all you know history should be
the most uh exciting subject and uh so
often it's reduced to uh you know rote
uh memorization and um i don't remember
having exciting uh history classes and i
think that i
like a lot of um people out there
discover some some people were lucky
enough to have fantastic history
teachers i don't mean to denigrate you
know all history teachers but i think
that my story like a lot of other people
i've met they're suddenly in their 30s
and 40s and one day they kind of on
their own you know pick up a piece of
history or biography and they start
reading and they say oh my god this is
fascinating how come i never felt that
uh before and we're having that um uh
sensation constantly uh with the show
that people are coming and uh saying uh
how come no teacher
let me know how passionate
and um uh brilliant and argumentative
and fascinating these characters were
last time we visited it was for your
washington book a book as big as the
alexander hamilton book even a little
bigger yeah
and now what are you doing i'm doing
ulysses s grant but you're right in the
middle of this trying to live in these
different centuries how hard is it
extremely hard because um mornings and
afternoons during the week
in the civil war and reconstruction some
in the 19th century
then
nights and weekends with the show and
back in the 18th century
occasionally when i come up for air i'm
in the early 21st century
but only occasionally and you know i
find usually because my books are very
long they're packed with information
um that when i finish a book brian
usually there's a delete button in my
mind
that just wipes out the whole book it's
like my mind is tired of having
sustained
all of this information whereas i've not
only had to keep
the entire ulysses s grant book
suspended in my mind but because of the
show of uh hamilton and even
washington so sometimes i feel like my
brain is bursting with these uh these
books and my
mind is crying for
release
when will you finish the grant book and
when will it be released to the public
um i'm hoping to finish the book this
year and that it will come out next year
um i've just had so many um
distractions with the show pleasant
distractions with the show but still
distractions uh that every time i think
that um the interest in the show is
going to start to subside it actually
intensifies so i would love if it if
grand comes out next year i'm not
positive it will what do you think of
him
well you know i always look in
in terms of searching for topics i
always look for people who i think
were
misunderstood
uh you know with hamilton hamilton had
been uh very demonized when i was
growing up
the uh view of that era was that
jefferson was this pure and virtuous man
he was the tribune of the common people
and uh hamilton was this you know
villainous uh figure and he was a tool
of the plutocrats and you know i tried
to show that uh you know hamilton uh was
really you know much more liberal figure
than he had been uh portrayed
uh and jefferson may be less so and you
know similarly with with grant i always
try to uh start out with uh some of the
myths that have hardened around some and
grant the butcher as a general well he
was actually strategic genius militarily
were
granted drunkard well that turns out to
be a very uh complicated uh uh story uh
grant the president
whose presidency was riddled with
corruption and um nepotism well that was
there but hardly the whole story i mean
reconstruction was the big story of his
presidency so i feel that there's so
much that
has been
forgotten by
ulysses s grant that i'm hoping that
when the book comes out it will be as
surprising
to most people as the hamilton book or
the other books have been that they're
just going to see so many more
dimensions to this figure you got to
pick one if you
were able to interview george washington
alexander hamilton or u.s grant or throw
in john d rockefeller in that which you
wrote
jp morgan morgan
who would you choose i i would choose
george washington um just because i i
feel of all the figures that i've
written about he was the
most important and
uh the most mysterious and just to kind
of be able to stare at him and study him
i mean if i wanted someone who was just
going to dazzle me with his his
intellect um
clearly alexander uh
hamilton um but i think that um
washington
as james d flexner said many years ago
was the uh the indispensable man who
made everything else happen and
um but i think that in in writing about
hamilton i certainly you know came to to
feel that uh you know his achievements
were up there with washington we found
some video that lynn miranda put on
youtube when he was a young boy and i
just wonder i know if you've seen this
or not we'll go ahead and roll it and
want to know if there's any video of you
anywhere that would exhibit this kind of
talent
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning
[Applause]
yeah this is before hip-hop i suspect
and all that uh anything like that i do
i i think it's safe to say uh brian that
no such video exists in the chernow
family archives sort of bouncing off the
ball you know dancing around on my uh on
my bed i was probably out playing stick
ball or doing something else has anybody
shown any interest in doing a broadway
show on washington
there's been a lot of interest in doing
dramatizations
of washington both in terms of
television and in terms of films so i'm
hoping that that will happen at some
point you know i have to tell you when
when lynn first told me that hamilton's
life was a classic hip-hop song and that
hip-hop had this perfect fit with
hamilton i didn't understand what he was
talking about but
i understand now because there's
something particularly the way that lynn
presents him in the show hamilton is
presented
as this very um very intense driven
almost frenetic character and here you
have this very kind of dense rapid you
know hip-hop music and there is
something about that personality and
that musical style that perfectly
meshed so it took me time to see what
must have come to linen just one great
blinding flash that this life and this
music would match my last question we
are almost out of time has there been
anybody that didn't like the show that
wrote about it
um
the only review that i could remember
that was at all critical was uh in the
uh the new yorker uh by hilton ales um
but um otherwise
we've had hundreds upon hundreds of
ecstatic reviews of the uh of the show
so i think it's inevitable that someone
would come along when you have everyone
saying this is the greatest show they've
ever seen somebody will inevitably come
along and say i don't think it's so
great did you know that this was going
to happen when you headed into this show
no but although you know what happened i
remember that back in january 2012 uh
lynn did a performance of about maybe 10
or 12 of the songs at jazz at lincoln
center
and i went and the audience
was full of people in their 20s and 30s
and they weren't even staged
really and he caught up with some of the
other
cast members and sang these songs and i
could remember that at the end
all of these young people in their 20s
and 30s were on their feet
cheering
screaming
stomping and i looked around and said oh
my god is this a preview
of the future and anytime that the
material was tested out
in front of an audience the responsible
extraordinary then i remember we had
went to a summer theater festival at
vassar powerhouse theater festival
and the place was crawling with um
producers from new york they did just
the first act and it was done concert
style every producer in the room
not only wanted to invest in every
producer was saying this is like the
greatest thing i've ever seen so
we had
we had intimations that it might happen
but i think
what we couldn't have predicted was uh
that it would be
quite such a sensation or that it would
be not only a theatrical phenomenon but
a political and culture phenomenon we
were all at the white house a couple of
weeks ago i don't think there's ever
been a sitting president united states
who came twice to see the show first
lady who's come to see the show
twice you know so we've had the obamas
we've had the clintons we've had the
cheneys we've had every
um you know hollywood and broadway star
that you could imagine there it's just
been a nightly who's who parade passing
through there was that's something that
none of us could have
imagined that it would be quite this
kind of sensation
ron chernow author of hamilton which is
now a successful broadway show thank you
very much
always a pleasure brian thank you
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
qna.org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
if you like this q and a program with
the story in ron chernow you can also
watch our two-part interview with him
from 2010 where we talked about his
biography of george washington other
interviews you might enjoy include
michelle easton of the claire booth
loose policy institute an organization
that was named after the former diplomat
and playwright and author david o
stewart who's been a guest on our
program twice first in 2007 on his book
on the founding of the u.s constitution
and again in 2015 for his book about
james madison you can find these
programs online at cspan.org